au commencement la musique africaine en
martinique
c'était ça puis il ya eu
aurlus mahb et les olives en goma et
monique séka
[Musique]
mais aussi balou quant à magic system et
auparavant mais oui
[Musique]
mais il ya dix ans est apparu le
phénomène fisc web deux jumeaux venue de
les gosses ils ont toutes explosé
[Applaudissements]
depuis la musique nigériane est partout
david o wizz kid des oies sauvages au
kiss dernière
en martinique aujourd'hui pas une soirée
ou presque sans une séquence d'afrobeat
ce soir-là en habitation de base un dj
fait danser 2500 pers
ses musiques et quand même facile tu
vois mon corps on essaie de l'imposant
soirée parce que mine de rien on a des
origines africaines aux antilles est
donc ses rythmes et ça met de l'ambiance
et puis c'est un peu le mouvement actuel
quoi bon quand c'est bien de l'imposant
m'a enseigné aussi chez nous on adore
caribéen l'afrobeat a envahi également
les radios en martinique
ici à trace fm les programmateurs comme
les d'auditeurs en raffolent c'est
lettonie joya canton les capte en fait
on a un peu le sentiment quelque
penderie entendre un petit peu nos
sonorités quand même quelque part est
souvent certains font le rap aussi en
disant oui mais
voilà ils font du zouk ou allait mettre
le pied dans le plat les nigérians font
du zouk alors je ne sais pas s'ils font
du zouk mais ils font une espèce de
sonorités qui nous rappelle les choses
ces sonorités ne sont pas complètement
étranger au fait quand elles arrivent
ici l'afrobeat envahi enfin les cours de
danse comme ici au choc culturel camille
darsières et les élèves s'en donnent à
coeur joie
la secousse était l'erreur donc tout
c'était que les récollets l'école et ray
est là pour avec la phobie c'est libre
quand on regarde les africaines ans et
on voit qu'ils sont toujours dans des
limites dans des comédies c'était atral
aussi on a l'impression qu'ils se
racontent une histoire
donc en fait c'est ça aussi que je
demande c'est pas exécuter exécuté je
recopie ce que je vois sur internet
il faut effectivement prendre le
mouvement mais se l'approprier aussi 90
élèves qui préparent ainsi leur
spectacle de fin d'année sur des rythmes
du nigeria l'afrobeat a conquis petits
et grands à la martinique
[Musique]
rigueur